i'm dr tara stowinski president and ceo
and chief scientific officer of the
diane fosse gorilla fund
and i'm here to talk about each great
ape that's featured in the new planet of
the apes trilogy
what a lot of people don't realize is
that humans are considered great apes as
well
great apes are a group of animals called
hominids there's actually eight species
but you might be familiar with the four
most common types which are chimpanzees
gorillas orangutans and bonobos
[Music]
chimpanzees
chimpanzees are the most featured ape in
the planet of the apes trilogy although
caesar is shown to be a pet in the movie
chimpanzees and actually all primates do
not make good pets for a chimpanzee to
be a pet it has to be taken away from
its mother at quite a young age and
mother infant bonds and chimpanzees and
all the great apes just like in humans
are incredibly strong so that's a very
traumatic experience for a young
chimpanzee
chimpanzees communicate with each other
using a variety of both gestural and
vocal communication the same way we do
and they have a pant hoot which is a
very loud sound that they make when
they're excited maybe when they find a
good food or if they hear other
chimpanzees in the region
so caesar communicates with humans in
the movie using sign language in the
1960s and 70s sign language was a really
interesting
area of research with chimpanzees but
actually with all of the great apes so
every one of the great apes each species
has actually been taught to use sign
language
and one of the amazing things about
chimpanzees is they have the widest
distribution of any of the great apes
they can live in rainforests or they can
live in savannahs as well on the western
side there's the western subspecies and
they live in countries like senegal and
mali and then you have the nigeria
cameroon chimpanzee which not
surprisingly is found in nigeria and
cameroon then there is the central
chimpanzee and they're found in gabon
the republic of congo equatorial guinea
and then on the far east side you have
the eastern chimpanzee and they live in
countries like rwanda burundi and
tanzania
when caesar overtakes rocket for alpha
status he is showing one of the classic
hallmarks of chimpanzee behavior so male
chimpanzees have linear dominance
hierarchies and they definitely compete
over the course of their life to be
dominant and the reason for that is
related to reproduction so dominant male
chimpanzees sire the majority of
offspring in the movies caesar is
portrayed when he has a infant as sort
of a king and queen type situation the
two of them together and that is not
actually what we see in chimpanzee
society chimpanzees have a mating system
that is called promiscuous where males
mate with multiple females and females
also mate with multiple males i think
one of the most incredible things about
chimpanzees that's been shown is that
they actually have protocultures that
are just like human culture so culture
is something that is not something you
learn in your environment but it's
actually passed on socially so it's
passed on generation to generation and
researchers have documented that
chimpanzees in the wild have these
different cultures so they have
different behaviors that have nothing to
do with their environment but rather
have been created by someone in their
group and then passed on over time
through social learning
in the movie you see chimps using
weapons quite a bit this is not
something we generally see a lot of in
the wild however there have been
examples of chimpanzees throwing sticks
and other objects down on human or other
observers probably the closest example
are there are chimpanzees in west africa
who have been observed using sticks kind
of as spears and putting them in holes
to try and stab another species of
primate called a bush baby
in the planet of the ape trilogies we
see the chimpanzees walking upright
quite a bit and chimpanzees and other
great apes can certainly do this they
can walk upright although they generally
don't do it for long periods of time and
it's really because these animals are
well adapted for living in the trees and
so the way that their bodies function
and are formed to enable them to climb
makes it really difficult for them to
walk upright for long periods of time
bonobos
bonobos and chimpanzees look very
similar bonobos are slightly smaller
than chimpanzees and that led to them
being called pygmy chimpanzees for a
long time but we know them as a
different species they're not just a
different type of chimpanzee they're
their own species but they are smaller
they also are born with a very dark face
whereas chimpanzees are born with a
light face that darkens over time and
those are kind of some of the big
physical differences
bonobos have the most restrictive range
of any of the great apes so they are
found in only one country democratic
republic of the congo and they are found
south of the congo river whereas
chimpanzees and gorillas are found north
of the congo river so they actually are
the only great ape that lives in this
particular part of congo
what's really different about the way
that coba is portrayed in planet of the
apes is it's very unbonobo like where we
see more striking differences is in
their behavior so he's a very aggressive
individual and in actuality bonobos are
really considered kind of pacifists they
are very playful they keep their playful
personality as adults they're known for
being very calm using sex rather than
aggression to settle fights really it's
chimpanzees in the wild that have the
more aggressive personality that you see
being portrayed in coba
in the movie you see that koba and
caesar are split over their relationship
with humans in the wild we don't see
that there is animosity towards humans
generally it's the opposite where humans
are aggressive and attack or kill great
apes
human
work
human work what we do see though is
animosity within a species bonobos are
actually the only species where that
hasn't been observed actually when
groups come together they can be quite
friendly now what has happened in some
places particularly with chimpanzees is
that where human communities and
chimpanzee communities have come close
together so for example where humans
have deforested areas and chimpanzees
are left in small little isolated forest
patches we have seen chimpanzees attack
humans and i think it's not an animosity
thing that they're actually viewing
humans as a source of prey and actually
just recently there was the first ever
recorded sighting of chimpanzees killing
a gorilla even after 50 plus years of
watching these animals in the wild it
was just observed for the first time
earlier this year
gorillas in the movie the gorillas are
really portrayed as the guards and i
think a lot of that is just a result of
their sheer size gorillas are amazing
they are the world's largest primate
they start at four pounds at birth and
males can grow to be 400 pounds
there's four types of gorillas in total
and only one of those four are found in
zoos and in west africa there are two
subspecies there's the cross river
gorilla and then there's the western
lowland gorilla and that's the type of
gorilla you can see in a zoo there's a
big area in the central part of africa
where you don't find gorillas at all
that's where you find the bonobos in
eastern africa there are another two
species they're the mountain gorillas
and they're the gorillas that were made
famous by diane fosse and are featured
in the movies gorillas in the mist and
then there's one called the growers
gorillas and like bonobos they are only
found in the democratic republic of
congo
male and female gorillas are the same
exact size until about the age of eight
and at that point female gorillas are
considered adults and they sort of grow
a lot more slowly until about 12 when
they're full size male gorillas however
at that age are really they enter a
phase called the black back phase so
it's kind of an adolescence and they
really shoot up in size and they
continue growing until about the age of
15 and at that point they've gained
their adult characteristics a male
gorilla is called a silverback it's just
a process of maturation so every male
gorilla becomes a silverback so just
like human males at a certain age get
broader chests and facial hair male
gorillas around the same age will again
get that broad chest a big head and the
hair on the back will turn silver and
that's a sign that they've reached
adulthood and male gorillas are really
they are in charge of their family so
they decide when it's time to eat when
it's time to rest where the family is
going to sleep at night they really are
the protectors of their family unit and
in the wild the males really do take on
this guard role i mean all of that size
and strength the purpose of it is to
defend their family and to defend their
family from other groups of gorillas and
this is particularly evident with young
gorillas if they lose their moms and in
that situation they basically will be
taken under the wing of the dominant
silverback even if it's not their kid
they will still take on responsibility
for allowing this infant to feed near
them so they can still have access to
good food the infants will often travel
near them and they'll even sleep with
them at night in their nest so i do
think this portrayal of male gorillas as
protectors and planet of the apes really
gets at the core of what male gorillas
are in their own families
a couple of cool things about gorillas
when diane fossey started her pioneering
work to study them 54 years ago the
common perception of gorillas were king
kong ferocious beast and when she
studied them and got to know them as
individuals and got to see their family
social structure she really changed the
narrative and so gorillas are actually
known as now as gentle giants gorillas
are strict vegetarians so don't ever let
anyone tell you you can't get big and
strong just by eating your vegetables
gorillas are always black but they do
have a lot of color variation
particularly in the western species you
will get a lot of red particularly
around their heads and then they have
that silver back but i've never seen a
red gorilla in the films there's a white
gorilla named winter but we have not
observed any white gorillas in the wild
there was one in a zoo in spain his name
was snowflake but white gorillas would
really not camouflage well in the dark
forest environments of africa
orangutans
maurice in the movie is seen as a very
wise and smart ape and certainly
orangutans are incredibly intelligent
there is a joke that said if you were to
give a screwdriver to a chimpanzee they
break it if you gave it to a gorilla
they'd throw it away and if you gave it
to an orangutan they would sort of
squirrel it away and then at some point
use it to dismantle you know whatever
was in the room so they are known for
their incredible intelligence
orangutans are the only great ape found
in asia so they live on the islands of
borneo and sumatra orangutans are
divided into three species up until
recently actually two were only
recognized the bornean and the sumatran
and then in 2017
the tapanuli orangutan was also
described
they are a beautiful red color and have
incredibly long arms that really is
because of the particular niche that
they fill so they are the most forgivers
of all the apes meaning they rely a lot
on fruit this part of their diet makes
it hard for them to live in social
groups so you can imagine if you're a
200 pound male orangutan and you need to
find enough food to eat and you come
across a food tree if there's 12 other
orangutans in that fruit tree that fruit
is going to be gone pretty quickly and
as a result they spend a lot of time
high up in the trees and so these long
arms enable them to kind of move from
branch to branch and span across these
treetops as they move through the forest
looking for food so orangutans actually
are primarily solitary whereas the
african great apes live in social groups
orangutans spend most of their lives as
solitary individuals and the males in
particular have this really unique look
so they have what are called flanges
around their face so these cheek pads
around their face it's one of their
secondary sexual characteristics and
they emit these very loud long calls
because these animals are solitary so
they need to communicate with other
orangutans over a much larger distance
than say a gorilla might who lives in a
close-knit social family
humans
a lot of people don't realize but humans
are also considered a great ape so
they're kind of the fifth type of grade
eight in the movie we see complex
relationships between humans and great
apes and i think the same exists you
know in real life unfortunately for
great apes humans are really their
greatest threat whether it be through
habitat destruction through poaching
climate change we are unfortunately
pushing grade eight populations to the
brink of extinction but i think one of
the reasons that these movies resonate
so much with people is because we see so
much of ourselves in great apes they
share the same emotions as us they share
the same kinds of relationships that we
do and so my hope is when people see
movies like planet of the apes they
recognize kind of the common humanity
that we have with our closest relatives
and that makes people interested in
preserving them in the wild that these
aren't going to be just animals that we
might see in a zoo or in a movie but
that these animals will retain their
incredible cultures and social lives in
the wild as well
to me one of the best things about the
planet of the eight movies is that no
actual apes were in these movies the
fact that these are all
computer-generated apes with humans
behind them to me is incredible and the
technology is amazing and i was lucky
enough to get to work with andy circus
when he was actually preparing to be
kong in the king kong movies and i think
that his portrayal of apes is
truly amazing i mean he really captures
just the subtleties of the way they move
and interact great apes are so much like
us
like us they have friends and enemies
like us they have emotions
like us they have really rich complex
social lives and so i think you know my
career as a primatologist and a
conservationist i hope that we can
cohabitate together maybe a little bit
better than the apes did in the planet
of the apes trilogy